[Music]
robert dubois
he's in prison for putting superman in
the icu with a kryptonite bullet i'm not
joining you suicide squad
we'll see my court date is coming up
i miss wallace and maybe you could help
me out you're flinching in my door
everyone stand down this wall stand down
i won't take such extreme measures this
mission went more important than you
could possibly imagine
are you in or out good
let's meet your team it's okay i'm not
okay
each member has chosen for his or her
own completely unique set of abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late let's go number
two good to know
is this thing a a dog what kind of dog
do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound
oh my god is it a werewolf y'all next
time
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel he's harmless
i mean he's not harmless he's killed 27
children but you know
your mission is to destroy every trace
of something known
only as project starfish any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no no
all right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
ratatouille what do you got bird
now now it stay off the calm
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business these are dangerous
people
team two is clear to go fire uh three
two what are you guys doing what
you we're here to save you you were
gonna save me it was a really good plan
too well i can go back inside and you
can still do it that's patronizing i'm
so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
can i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for fun here's the deal
we fail the mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth really although that
isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell am i
supposed to know you're the leader
you're supposed to be decisive and i've
decided that you should eat a big bag of
dicks
if this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
the beans well that's why mad men do
what they
[Music]
this is do well that's kind of our thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've gotta freaking kaiju up
in this
[Applause]
[Music]
love the [ __ ] like angels are splooting
all over us
[Music]
you